[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: "Ain't Too Proud"
follows the Temptations'
journey from the
streets of Detroit
to the Rock and
Roll Hall of Fame.
With their signature dance moves
and unmistakable harmonies,
they rose to the
top of the charts,
creating an amazing
42 top 10 hits,
with 14 reaching number one.
Through friendship and
betrayal, amid the civil unrest
that tore America apart, their
moving and personal story still
resonates five decades later.
[MUSIC - "MY GIRL," THE
TEMPTATIONS]
[MUSIC - "AIN'T TOO PROUD," THE
[MUSIC - "GIRL, WHY YOU WANNA
MAKE ME BLUE," THE TEMPTATIONS]
[MUSIC - "GET READY," THE
TEMPTATIONS]
[CHEERS]
SPEAKER 1: Let's
welcome the cast.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you so much
for joining us.
DERRICK BASKIN:
Thanks for having us.
SPEAKER 1: No problem.
DERRICK BASKIN: That's our
first time seeing that.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, yeah?
DERRICK BASKIN: That
was really cool.
SPEAKER 1: I was
over here jammin'.
JAMES HARKNESS: Look, Derrick.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: Everyone take a
moment to introduce yourselves.
JAMES HARKNESS: Hey,
I'm James Harkness.
I play Paul Williams.
JEREMY POPE: Good afternoon.
I'm Jeremy Pope.
I play Eddie Kendricks.
DERRICK BASKIN: Good morning.
[LAUGHTER]
My name is Derrick Baskin.
I play Otis Williams.
JAWAN M. JACKSON: Hey, y'all.
I'm Jawan Jackson.
I play Melvin Franklin.
SPEAKER 1: So again, thank
you again for being here.
I mean this trailer tells
the story of it all.
The Temptations have
been successively
active since the 1960s.
How important or
relevant is the show
for audience today, considering
the musical landscape?
JAMES HARKNESS: I think it's
incredibly relevant today.
One of the things that
I love about-- there's
so many things that is
great about this story.
One of the things is that
it took them a minute
before they hit number one.
And right now, we're in a
time where social media plays
such a huge part of
everyone's lives,
and everything is
almost instantaneous.
And you have these kids that
are coming out and they have,
like, 13,000 followers
or more, and they
think that it's going
to happen right away.
And it doesn't really
happen right away
to get something
that's really great
and something that's
going to last.
And as you know about
The Temptations,
their music has lasted
all of these years
and it is still incredibly
relevant, and it is still--
it's timeless, but it took
them a second to get there.
And I think that's something
very important for people
to understand about them.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
What about their
personas really drew you
into these individual roles?
JEREMY POPE: I grew up
listening to The Temptations.
My parents would always
play The Temptations album--
the Christmas
album, specifically,
and that's how I knew that it
was time to trim the Christmas
tree and get it ready.
[LAUGHTER]
Because Christmas
was now upon us.
But I think what I've
learned through the show
and working on this piece
is just the struggles
and the sacrifices these men--
the things they
had to go through.
Their music was in
the middle-- smack dab
in the middle of the
Civil Rights movement,
and it charged that movement.
And what it must have felt
like to be wanted as an artist
but for who you are and
the color of your skin
to be denied of that.
They were performing for
segregated audiences.
And I can only imagine
what that felt like--
must have felt like, and
just the questions and things
they had to go through
as individuals.
But to kind of see, on
the end, now we're able
to-- they've granted us
an opportunity to continue
the legacy--
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JEREMY POPE: --and to tell the
story of these incredible men.
And we get to humanize them
and talk about the good times,
but also their ugly truths.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JEREMY POPE: And I
think that is beautiful.
That is the beauty of what
it is that we're doing.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
I think that that
was something that
resonated with me when I
saw the show, that ugly truth.
It wasn't just all
stars and lights,
but actual real life happening
during such a time of unrest.
How did each of
you prep for taking
on your individual roles?
JAWAN M. JACKSON: I
can start with that.
I'm born and raised
in Detroit, so I think
this is a thing that's been--
[APPLAUSE]
Yeah, give it up.
313, through and through.
[LAUGHTER]
And so growing up with
this music, I think, once--
once it came about,
I've always wanted
to play Melvin Franklin,
and just somebody that
is not highly represented in
my vocal category, you know?
And so I only had,
growing up, Michael McCary
from Boyz II Men.
You had Lou Rawls,
Barry White, and then
Melvin Franklin, who's the
epitome of basses in R&B.
And so this is just a character
study, and I took my time
and did my research.
And my cousin dated
Melvin when I was--
I have a story about that.
DERRICK BASKIN: No,
I didn't know that.
JAWAN M. JACKSON: No?
I've always told that story.
My cousin dated him when
they were in high school.
DERRICK BASKIN: Really?
JAWAN M. JACKSON: Yeah, they
went to the same high school
together.
And she's like, you know,
I dated Melvin for a while.
[LAUGHTER]
He was always sweet.
I could never keep him up
because everybody was always
over him.
So I was like, OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
[LAUGHTER]
Melvin could have
been my cousin.
[LAUGHTER]
I think Melvin has been a part
of me in my life for so long,
so it was easy
once the role came.
DERRICK BASKIN: But we also--
this show, for all of us,
it's a marathon, you know?
It really is a very taxing show
on your body, on your spirit,
on your soul.
So practically, we have to--
I have to go to
the gym every day.
I have to work out.
I have to stretch and warm up.
But I also have to hydrate.
This is my third or
fourth bottle of water
since I've woken up.
And then I can't
just drink water.
Now I have to
drink coconut water
to make sure I have
electrolytes and all that stuff.
And I have to prepare for
that now so that by 8 o'clock,
I'll be ready to
actually do the show.
And it just takes--
it's a lot of upkeep
to do this particular musical.
But the subject matter that we--
every night that we visit,
it requires us to also
be very grounded spiritually.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN:
Because we are really,
really good friends off stage.
And on stage, we play
brothers, essentially.
And a lot of times,
not so much with me
and Jawan, but sometimes
with me and Jeremy,
we have to do some very
intense scene work.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: And we have
to make sure that we feel safe
with each other.
And I can't take
it personally when
he is yelling at me because it's
actually not him yelling at me.
It's Eddie yelling at Otis.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: But sometimes,
as an artist, we get really--
really entwined
with our characters.
And you have to just really
be grounded, spiritually
and emotionally, to
play such an emotionally
and spiritually-charged show.
So you have to make
sure, whatever--
I pray.
I pray, I read the Bible.
I think we all meditate.
I got to take up yoga now.
I just need to
breathe, you know?
It's just a lot to--
it's a lot to deal with.
And it's a big responsibility
because you really want
to honor these guys, you know?
We stand on their shoulders.
They've paved the way for us.
So had Otis Williams not
done what he did, I--
who am playing him--
cannot do what I'm doing.
And so it's a heavy
responsibility,
but it's also a blessing.
SPEAKER 1: Sure.
DERRICK BASKIN: So we have
to prepare in each way
that we can, in every
way that we can,
so that we can really honor
these guys every night.
SPEAKER 1: Well,
speaking of physicality
and just well-being,
Ephraim Sykes is not here.
He's resting his voice.
But what do each of you do?
What are your regimens to make
sure you stay in the best shape
possible?
Starting with you, Jeremy.
JEREMY POPE: Well, I have--
DERRICK BASKIN: [CLEARS THROAT]
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY POPE: --a lot of things.
No, I give it up
to my vocal coach,
who I've been working with
intensely this season, Liz
Kaplan, who has just
helped me stay grounded.
And I think my whole
big thing this season--
and I say the season, and us
joining and doing this marathon
of a show is just no stress.
I feel like when
you stress, that's
when your body wants to break
down and your voice gets tight.
And I'm only in control of
the things I can control.
And I do hold the responsibility
of how important this show is,
and I know that I have to show
up for the show every night
because I know that
I'm being used.
It feels like when
we're on stage,
it's not about Jeremy
Pope or Derrick Baskin.
It feels like it's the higher
calling and I'm just a vessel.
And people are seeing
Eddie Kendricks,
or they're seeing Paul Williams.
So it's kind of like you
just show up for that,
and know that the greater good
is going to work itself out.
So in that, it's just, like
Derrick said, going to the gym
and making sure I'm
drinking enough water
and just staying
hydrated, and trying
not to stress about things
that I can't control.
So that when we get to
the show, we huddle up.
Every time before we go on
stage, we hold each other.
And we just tune in
and go, you good?
And sometimes the answer is no.
And we say, OK, I
got you because I
know that I can't do this
show without my brothers.
I know that I'm not in it alone.
Really, our whole cast.
We have a prayer circle for
people that want to come in.
Most of us get in that
circle and just breathe.
That's what we start with.
Everyone, breathe
in and breathe out.
Breathe out the negative.
You know, anything negative.
Anything that's just
not going to help
service you to do what
you're about to do.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JEREMY POPE: So that we can
make it to the finish line,
and we do every night, you know?
And I'm so grateful
for these guys.
So I know that, in my prep,
it's stuff that I do at home,
it's my vocal lessons,
it's my exercising,
it's staying hydrated.
But it's also just
leaning on these guys
and being there
for them because I
know that's a part of
the process as well.
JAMES HARKNESS: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: James, talk
to us a little bit
about the audition process.
And I absolutely want to
hear from each of you.
Talk to us about the
process, the research.
But then also how
you got the call
and what happened after that.
JAMES HARKNESS: Well, it
was a long audition process,
but it was one of the most fun
audition processes I've ever
been through.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
JAMES HARKNESS: Because
there was so much
love throughout
this whole process.
And as far as
research is concerned,
the initial call was for
"The Detroit Project."
And we knew it was
about The Temptations.
So of course you're
going to go and listen
to whatever Temptations
music you can find,
or go surf YouTube
and find any videos.
But you also have to
just open yourself
up to whatever the
process is going to be
when you walk into the room.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JAMES HARKNESS: So for
me, the first thing
was it was a dance audition.
It was a huge dance audition.
Now, mind you, I talked
my way into the audition.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
JAMES HARKNESS: I actually--
[LAUGHTER]
I was never called
in for this process.
A lot of people were
invited through their agents
or managers or whatnot.
I was not.
And the day before,
the show that I
was doing at the time, all
the other guys were going in
and one of them turned
to me and was like,
are you going to this
audition tomorrow or not?
And so I went--
[SIGHS]
I picked up my phone.
I sent a text message
to Sergio Trujillo, who
is our choreographer,
and I just said,
hey, it's been a minute
since we've spoken
and I know you're doing this
Temptations thing tomorrow.
I would love to be in the room,
but I also understand if not.
And a minute later, I got
a message back saying,
please come.
So I came.
And here I am sitting here.
So it all worked out.
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY POPE: Most
important text message.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES HARKNESS: But it was a
long, but incredible process.
One of the things I loved about
auditioning for this show,
as I said earlier, was the love.
A lot of times, you audition
for things and I don't know,
it's not the same as
going in on an interview.
In an audition room, everyone's
in the room and everyone
is doing it at the same time,
especially in a dance call.
So every single person, we're
all learning the choreography
at the same time, and we're
either in groups of five
or more when we audition.
Or, as what happened in this
one, Sergio was like, OK, guys.
We're going to go one by one.
DERRICK BASKIN: Yeah.
JAMES HARKNESS: And
everyone was like, what?
[LAUGHTER]
You know?
So then you have everyone's
eyes on you watching.
But what was beautiful
about this process
is everyone
supported each other.
SPEAKER 1: That's great.
JAMES HARKNESS: And I have
been auditioning for a while,
and I have never felt
what I felt in the rooms
for these auditions.
Because everyone
was with each other,
going, hey, giving
each other support
and cheering each other on.
And if someone didn't
really know the step,
someone would help the other
person out with the step.
That doesn't always happen.
Because as you know,
a lot of times,
you're trying to get
what you need to get.
And that's a lot of
things about this world.
A lot of times, people
go through life going,
I need to get where
I need to get to.
One of the things
that's been great also
about being in this show,
just as Jeremy was saying,
people-- we're here
to support each other.
SPEAKER 1: As it should be.
JAMES HARKNESS: Because you
need someone's hand on your back
sometimes.
You need someone to
help guide you forward.
And that support
system, feeling that
from the beginning of
this process, was amazing.
The call.
Oh, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Yes, let's jump--
let's unpack it.
JAMES HARKNESS: Well,
there's two calls
that are very important
through this process for me.
So third audition, I had gone
in and finally auditioned
for Paul.
Initially, I went into
dance, and then we sang.
And then they gave
us sides to learn,
which were sides for some
of the secondary characters.
I went and auditioned for
that, and then the director
looked at me and he
said, hold on a minute.
He turned to his assistant.
They were like (WHISPERING)
chirp, chirp chirp, chirp,
chirp.
[LAUGHTER]
And then he rifled
through some papers
and then he held this out and
he said, here, go read for Paul
and come back in when
you're ready to do it.
So I went out into the
hallway, learned the stuff,
came back in and
auditioned for Paul.
This is my third audition.
I get back to work.
All the guys that had gotten
their callbacks already,
so this is about
7 o'clock, 7:15.
No, it was a half hour, 7:30.
So sorry, this was about 7:45.
[LAUGHTER]
And they're like
callbacks and they're
talking about the stuff.
And I'm sitting there going, OK.
Well, all right.
I didn't get one.
But I also went, but I'm
OK because the process has
been so good--
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JAMES HARKNESS: --that if this
is where it ends for me, sucks,
yes because I really,
really, really want this.
But it's also OK because the
process has been so great.
Pop, pop, pop, pop.
All these messages
come up on my phone
and then I see one from my
manager, so I was just like--
[LAUGHTER]
And it said, hey, buddy.
You got your callback.
And I was sitting in my
chair and I was like, yes.
And I started laughing, and then
I immediately started crying.
And one of my castmates
looked at me and he was like,
are you doing a scene right now?
[LAUGHTER]
And I was like, no.
I'm kind of famous
for doing scenes.
But then I realized,
at that moment,
how bad I really, really wanted
it because I sat and I cried.
But I cried out of joy.
And so that was one call.
And then the call call was
after the last final audition,
where everyone was in the room.
Dominique was in the room, the
producers were in the room.
Everyone was there.
And did that whole audition,
was walking back to do my show.
I was in "Beautiful the
Musical" at the time.
I was walking with Clayton and
I found out that Clayton, who
plays one of the guys--
who plays one of the
guys in the show.
He's one of our cast members.
He was also up for Paul,
and I didn't know that
until that moment.
And we're walking down the
street and I just went, huh.
Clayton.
And I was like, great
because Clayton is amazing.
And I went, well, that's
where that role is going.
And I made peace
with it the next day.
Then I get a phone
call and my manager
was like, so how
was the audition?
And I was like, it was cool.
He was like, so how
do you think you did?
And I was like, the director
said I did a good job.
So I said, OK.
He fully set me up.
SPEAKER 1: Setting you up.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES HARKNESS: And
he was like so well,
I'm sorry to tell you--
and I was like, mmm, OK--
that you'll be doing double
duty for the next six weeks.
And double duty means I was
going to be rehearsing all day
and then also doing
my shows at night.
And I said-- well, I
can't say what I said--
[LAUGHTER]
--at that particular moment.
And then I started crying.
And-- surprise, surprise.
DERRICK BASKIN: Weeping willow.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JAMES HARKNESS: So
that is what happened.
Those were the two calls
that mean the most to me,
and I get to be here.
SPEAKER 1: That's wonderful.
What have you all
learned about yourselves
throughout the process of
auditioning, of course, getting
the call, but then also
playing these larger-than-life
personas?
DERRICK BASKIN: Well, I honestly
didn't know if I was actually
capable of doing so much work.
Before this show,
I'd play a sidekick
and I'd sing a really cool song.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: And
then that'd be it.
The show I did before
this show, I was a mute,
so I had no lines.
Go from that to doing like
50 million monologues.
I just wasn't sure I
was capable of carrying,
I guess, so much weight.
And this show showed
me how capable
I am of trying to
rise to a challenge.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: And
I think when you're
presented with any
kind of obstacle
or any kind of challenge, to be
able to rise to that, for me,
it was just kind
of life-affirming.
To say I actually can be
stronger than I think I am.
And I think a lot of times,
we have moments in our lives
where we're like, I
just don't think I'm
capable of doing x, y, or z.
And to be given an
opportunity to say,
actually, you're
actually stronger
than you think you are.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: I think
it taught me that I'm
stronger than I think I am.
SPEAKER 1: Are there
parallels between each of you
individually and the
characters that--
and the real-life personas
that you're playing?
Parallels in real life?
DERRICK BASKIN: Yes.
I'm going to say this.
So it's really weird and eerie
how each of us are very--
we're very close to the
personas that we play.
And I don't think--
I'm certain casting
didn't really know it.
The casting directors
didn't know it.
But I think we just--
I think the reason why we
all booked these roles is we
all are very similar
to our characters.
And it's eerie.
These two specifically.
Jawan has just one of
the biggest hearts.
He has just a great smile.
[LAUGHTER]
He is kind of the
warmth of our show.
And Jeremy, when I
first met Jeremy--
actually, we also
went on a vacation
together between one
of the two dates.
We went all the way to Bali.
And on the trip
to Bali, Jeremy is
thinking about some business.
He was like, all right, now what
can I do as an artist to make--
what can I do to
help brand the show?
Can I do anything?
I wasn't thinking
about the show.
But Jeremy, he's very
good at branding.
He's very good at
the business side
of things, which I think
Eddie Kendricks was also
very interested in, in
making sure that artists
were taking care of themselves.
That artists were taken care
of by the record companies.
And Jeremy is kind of like our
ringleader when it comes to OK,
whoever we're talking to
or wherever we're doing it,
are you taking care
of us as artists?
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: And that's
Jeremy's responsibility,
which is pretty much what Eddie
did, I think, with our group.
But it's the same with Ephraim.
You know, Ephraim has
this fire inside of him.
I don't think that he's as--
he's not actually
as dysfunctional
as David Ruffin was.
SPEAKER 1: Right, right.
DERRICK BASKIN:
He's actually not.
But he does have this fire
that I actually admire.
And then James, as well.
James has told you about
he'll cry about three or four
times in this interview.
But he is the heart and
the soul, he really is.
He wears his heart
on his sleeves.
And he has this sensitivity.
And so it's just
really interesting
how just everything that
we've gone through in life,
before we even got
to these roles,
have prepared us for the
roles that we are playing.
It's really cool the way that
life has paralleled that way.
SPEAKER 1: That's awesome.
DERRICK BASKIN: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Speaking
of chemistry,
you had touched on it earlier.
So the show works because you
all feed off of each other.
What is your favorite
song to perform and why?
JEREMY POPE: I'll go first.
JAWAN M. JACKSON: OK.
JEREMY POPE: My favorite
song that we do in the show,
I think, is "My Girl."
I think-- well, I
know it's because it's
the first time that the
classic five were all on stage
together.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JEREMY POPE: That
we kind of solidify,
we're The Temptations.
And I think it's the
moment in the show where
you begin to really hear
those classic Temptations
songs that you know.
So as soon as you hear that
bass line on "My Girl,"
that's when we hear the
audience singing back at us.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JEREMY POPE: And they're
ready because they
know we're about to get
into the good-- you know,
their favorite, favorite,
favorite Temptations songs.
JAWAN M. JACKSON:
We're in the show.
JEREMY POPE: So that is a
moment that I love in the show
the most, and the song
that I love the most.
SPEAKER 1: What about you?
JAMES HARKNESS: There's so many.
It's been hard to
nail this one down.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
JAMES HARKNESS: It
really has been.
But I will say that I
love doing "Get Ready."
SPEAKER 1: Oh, gosh.
JAMES HARKNESS: Because it--
now we're in Temptations
world, and this is also
a big hit for The Temptations.
But then there's also this
interview that happens right
in the middle of it.
And we've been doing a lot of
these wonderful interviews.
So there are times
when I'm also on stage,
and I'm looking at
us sitting on stage
in this onstage interview.
But then I go, but we just
did this earlier today.
[LAUGHTER]
And so it's a really,
really fascinating thing.
As Derrick was saying, we
really do bring these characters
to life.
We kind of personify
these people.
And there are so many times
when I'm looking at Eddie--
I mean--
JAWAN M. JACKSON: Jeremy.
DERRICK BASKIN: Jeremy.
SPEAKER 1: Jeremy.
JAMES HARKNESS: I'm
looking at Jeremy on stage,
but I'm seeing Eddie.
But I'm seeing Jeremy.
And it just kind of
starts to do this,
and it's a really,
really fascinating thing.
JEREMY POPE: It's
one of those things--
going back to the
last question, it's
just like you don't really want
to talk about it because you
don't really want to
get into-- you don't
want to figure out why that is.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JEREMY POPE: It just kind
of is and it's scary.
Like you said, it's eerie.
Because there's times where
I'm looking at Ephraim, who's
playing David Ruffin, and
it's like you don't want
to talk to him
because of the fire,
like how messed up
it seems, you know?
But there's still this love,
where you want to care for him.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JEREMY POPE: And I feel
that way with each of us,
that it's not us.
It's just something else.
And we kind of go, great,
you're acting real well today.
[LAUGHTER]
You know?
And you kind of just
leave it at that.
JAWAN M. JACKSON:
Oftentimes, too, we'll
get-- there's a
scene between Derrick
and I, which leads me into
my favorite song to hear
is "Just My Imagination"
right before that.
And that's the first time Melvin
gets mad and upset in the show.
And then sometimes,
he'll go off on me.
And then right when we
walk into the thing,
he's like, I'm sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
And so I'm like, it's
OK, it's OK, it's OK.
Or I roll my eyes,
like, do it again.
Do it again.
[LAUGHTER]
But then it leads into
"Just My Imagination,"
which is my favorite number
to listen to because Jeremy
Pope just steals the audience.
And if you didn't know about
his vocal abilities or anything
as Eddie Kendricks,
or you had questions,
they are debunked
there because that boy
sings the panties
and the drawers off
of anybody listening.
[LAUGHTER]
It's so great.
DERRICK BASKIN: Literally.
SPEAKER 1: Literally, yeah.
JAWAN M. JACKSON: It's amazing
to hear just in the stillness.
That's the first time,
I think, in the show
that we're actually, as
Temptations, just still
and you get to just
enjoy and listen
and be in the moment with
us and follow the journey.
And so that's one of
my favorite numbers.
SPEAKER 1: That's amazing.
Speaking of pulling the
spirit out of people,
I caught a few winks
during the show.
There were some winks thrown
out during the show when
I saw it on Tuesday.
There was a come
hither gesture that
was really engulfing everyone.
And then, of course,
at some point,
I believe it was Ephraim.
He threw a handkerchief out.
And I'm like, oh, snap.
Let me--
[LAUGHTER]
Let me grab--
DERRICK BASKIN: Did you get it?
JAWAN M. JACKSON:
Did you get it?
SPEAKER 1: --the handkerchief.
How important is
audience participation?
JAMES HARKNESS:
It's so important.
DERRICK BASKIN: Yeah.
JAWAN M. JACKSON: It
definitely makes the experience
a lot better for us.
JEREMY POPE: Yeah.
DERRICK BASKIN: Go ahead.
JEREMY POPE: I'll go.
We have the-- we
were very fortunate.
It feels fortunate now because
we did make it to Broadway.
But we had to go
out of town and we
went to a bunch of different
cities to just kind of mold
and figure out
what the show was.
So there was a
point in the process
where you had to go, OK,
how can I use these shows?
Because we're not in New York.
We're not there yet.
And we need to make sure
this show is the best
that it can be.
So we are very aware of the
audience and we have to be.
I feel like that is the
final character that
is added to your production.
And it's sometimes the
most important character
to the production, just to
hear where they're listening
and allow them into your story.
Because we're in the rehearsal
space doing our version of what
we think is the show.
Hold for applause and continue.
But sometimes, the
spirit moves and people
respond and don't
know why or how.
But we have to
leave room for that.
So the cool thing
is every night,
we are open to whatever they're
ready to say or feel or be
a part of.
Sometimes we have loud,
exuberant audiences
that are yelling at us.
And we're looking at
each other, like, I wish
I could hear my line, you know?
[LAUGHTER]
And we love that, you know?
And then sometimes we have
quiet ones where we're like,
do we need to check a pulse?
You know?
But we love them, as
well, because usually, we
get to the end of the show
and everyone is on their feet
and so excited.
And some people can kind
of coddle that energy
till the end and
some people just
have to shout amen and be
reaching for the handkerchief.
Because again, it's this
music that they've lived,
that they know.
And I think there
is this element
that it is a concert for them.
They get to relive these songs.
And we have performances
like "Get Ready,"
which are big numbers,
where it feels
like a big concert, a
Temptations concert.
But there's just so much
heart and so much story in it.
So for the people that
knew The Temptations,
they get to know them in
a deeper, intimate way.
And that's just
so, so incredibly
special to look
out in the audience
and see the older couple
with tears in their eyes.
And you just know that they're
going through something totally
different than the
young black kid who's
kind of on the edge of his seat
seeing himself represented.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
JEREMY POPE: And to
have those two stories
in the same room experiencing
this beautiful piece
is just really, really cool.
SPEAKER 1: Yeah,
I definitely felt
transported when I saw the show.
I was instantly drawn in
from the first number.
I want to talk a little
bit about logistics, just
a small portion.
The microphone situation.
So at some point, or
throughout the show,
there was a mini mic that
you guys would pull out
of your jacket pocket.
And I was wondering to
myself, wow, is that part of--
was that something that
you all came up with
or was that something that
would happen in real life
during the performances?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JEREMY POPE: Yeah, our
director and our choreographer.
One thing I will talk about,
and I know Ephraim would
talk about it here, is we had--
we were blessed to
have Otis Williams--
the last original founding
member of The Temptations
with us on this journey.
So he had seen a workshop and it
was our first day of rehearsal.
We were all together
and he came back
and he was talking to Ephraim,
who played David Ruffin.
He said, if you really
want to get David down,
when he'd really want to
get the audience wound
up and on their feet,
he would take a mic,
throw it in the air, and
then drop in a split.
SPEAKER 1: And there
were a lot of splits.
JEREMY POPE: And there was a--
so that's kind of the
task that he gave Ephraim.
But Ephraim is fearless and
was like, oh, yeah, I got you,
baby.
You know what I mean?
Come back tomorrow,
you know what I mean?
SPEAKER 1: Right, right.
[LAUGHTER]
JEREMY POPE: And
that is something
that he does every night.
He's talked about
it in interviews
of how he has to trust and
kind of surrender, you know?
Because it's terrifying to just
throw something up and go, OK,
gravity, have my back today.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JEREMY POPE: And there's been
shows where he's dropped it
and he's got another one
right outside of his pocket,
and the audience
still goes crazy.
[LAUGHTER]
But it's just so cool.
So that is something that they
used to do that David would do.
He would just take that mic up,
throw it up, drop into a split.
But this idea in
the choreography
that we all kind of have
mics just everywhere, just
who's singing what and
how they're doing that
was our director and our
choreographer, Sergio.
DERRICK BASKIN: Yeah.
And Dez is really good--
and Sergio-- they're
very good at transitions.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: And so to
make everything smooth,
sometimes you have
to tuck things
away so that you don't
have to say, OK, now
I need to go off and get a mic.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: If
it's just right here,
the moment is not-- the
energy isn't interrupted,
do you know what I mean?
James wears a flask
in act two in his vest
that he has to pull out.
And he's had that flask
at the top of the song,
but we don't use the flask for
minutes and minutes and minutes
later.
So there's nowhere he can
store it besides on his body
to keep the transition
going smoothly
so that the scenes
always go from moment
to moment to moment.
And so he'll have a mic on him.
He'll pass one to Ephraim,
or Ephraim will have one--
JEREMY POPE: Pass it to me.
DERRICK BASKIN: Yeah, yeah.
To make sure that
everything stays smooth.
This show is like a memory
play, so a lot of times,
people are sliding
in and sliding out,
and there's always a
movement to our show.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: And so in order
to keep that movement going,
we have to store things.
And extra ones, just in
case someone drops one,
there's one here
to keep it going.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: And so
yeah, it's interesting.
I don't have to hide
anything, thank god.
JEREMY POPE: But you have--
he has a lot of costume because
he doesn't leave the stage.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JEREMY POPE: So Derrick,
he won't tell you,
he doesn't leave the stage.
He is the last member, so
he is narrating this memory,
if you will.
So at the top of show,
he is a little thicker
because he's got--
JAMES HARKNESS: Eight costumes.
JEREMY POPE: --three
scenes underneath him
that you will then see.
So we have that on
top of hiding mics.
DERRICK BASKIN: Yeah, yeah.
SPEAKER 1: So speaking
of showmanship,
obviously the timeline
of The Tempts career
overlaps with many
of the other groups
that we all should
be familiar with,
such as The Supremes, who were
also very much into putting
on a performance.
So let's jump into a video here.
Derrick?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 2: And guess who had
to share the spotlight with us?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DERRICK BASKIN: Wow.
JEREMY POPE: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
That looked good.
DERRICK BASKIN: That
was pretty cool.
JAWAN M. JACKSON: That was the
first time we saw that too.
JEREMY POPE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
JAMES HARKNESS: They
got music videos.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Wow.
That's really cool.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 1: So let's
talk a little bit.
This is what I like to
call the fun section.
I mean, we were
already having fun,
but now we're going to
unpack some personal stuff.
JAMES HARKNESS: OK.
SPEAKER 1: Not really.
But what's your favorite
song to listen to when you're
kind of prepping for that day?
JAMES HARKNESS: That's hard
because I think we all listen
to just different things.
It's kind of whatever's
in the moment.
Sometimes whatever's coming
up on your shuffle play.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JAMES HARKNESS: I don't think
I listen to anything specific
to get me going.
There's always a Janet
Jackson song running.
SPEAKER 1: Of course.
DERRICK BASKIN: I mean, always.
JAMES HARKNESS: Always.
[LAUGHTER]
DERRICK BASKIN: Janet Jackson.
JAMES HARKNESS: That's
my girl, that's my girl.
[LAUGHTER]
DERRICK BASKIN: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMES HARKNESS:
But I don't know.
DERRICK BASKIN: For
me, it's Stevie Wonder.
He's my all-time
favorite artist.
So I mean, his
catalog is ridiculous.
And so I can always
turn to him if I
need any kind of inspiration.
If I need to get a little
bit more energy that day,
or if I need to calm down, it's
always a Stevie Wonder song
to get me in the mood, for sure.
"Songs in the Key of
Life," specifically.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, gosh.
DERRICK BASKIN: Yeah,
that thing is major.
It'll always be major.
JAMES HARKNESS: Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: What's your
dream show to book?
JEREMY POPE: Theater?
SPEAKER 1:
Theater-wise, for sure.
DERRICK BASKIN: I
mean, I will not
get any better than this show.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
DERRICK BASKIN: There is--
I don't believe there will be a
show created after this that I
will be more excited to do.
I've just never--
have never been
used to this extent
of my ability,
and I just don't
think any other show
that I do after this will
ask me to do as much as I'm
doing in this show.
And so this is the
dream, you know?
I will, God willing,
have more theater.
I would love to do a straight
play as opposed to musical
because it's so much easier.
[LAUGHTER]
JAWAN M. JACKSON:
It's so much easier.
DERRICK BASKIN: I can't--
I can't have any whiskey.
I'm not drinking right now.
I got to really
watch what I eat,
except for I didn't
watch what I ate today.
I ate in y'all cafeteria,
which is major.
[LAUGHTER]
But I just don't--
I just don't think
there is another piece
of musical theater that will
top this, in terms of what
it's asking all of us to do.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: So
yeah, this is my dream.
JEREMY POPE: Yeah, I think that.
Same, same, same.
And also, just what this piece
is pouring into me for me,
I just don't know--
I can't see anything
else because I'm just
so grateful to be with
these guys, with our cast.
Because it's providing healing
and so much love to me,
and giving me so much--
I don't know, just so much
support that I feel like--
I don't know.
I just feel incredible.
So I just don't know what other
project would give me that,
grant me that.
And specifically
with this show, it's
not every day that you see this
many black brothers on stage.
SPEAKER 1: Sure.
DERRICK BASKIN: Right.
JEREMY POPE: So a lot of
the times, it's between me
and him for a role.
It's between me-- so the fact
that we can all be in the same
room--
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JEREMY POPE: --and
that's fine, and everyone
gets to just be great and
a star in their own way,
I'm like, this is the dream.
That I get to look to my
brothers and my sisters
and be like, oh, we've made it.
We're doing something.
You're great, I'm great,
she's great, they're great.
We're great together
for the greater good,
for a greater calling.
JAMES HARKNESS: I think as
a man in this business, this
is definitely the dream.
They don't write roles
like this for men.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JAMES HARKNESS: Period.
In the musical,
especially, they do not
write roles like this for men.
And then to add on top of
that to write roles like this
for black men in theater--
SPEAKER 1: For sure.
JAMES HARKNESS: --where
we're not playing a thug,
we're not playing a slave.
We're not playing
things that people
look and are used to seeing.
We're playing five
intelligent, strong,
but also vulnerable men who've
lived an incredible life
and they've gone through things
that everyone understands.
There's nothing that
we're going through
that someone's going
to sit and go well,
I don't understand that because
they're a different skin
color than I. That doesn't
happen like this in this show.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JAMES HARKNESS: So to
have the opportunity
to play something like this,
it really is, as Derrick said--
I hope that this
is something that
shifts in theater, that
helps shift theater
and that helps writers
go, OK, we can do that.
We can do that in a musical.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JAMES HARKNESS: We
don't have to wait
to do a play to bring this
type of stuff to the table.
Because this is
what it feels like.
I've come out of the stage
door and people have said,
that is one of the best
plays I've ever seen.
It's a musical, but the work
that Dominique Morisseau has
done in this show,
also with our director,
it feels like a play that just
so happens that we're singing
and we're dancing.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JAMES HARKNESS: So it is an
incredibly powerful thing
that--
yeah, I hope in the
future that there
is something else that I
get to do that will bring me
to the level of this.
And not just for myself,
for all of us sitting
here and for everyone
else out there
who wants to do
this for a living
and is doing this for a living.
SPEAKER 1: Absolutely.
I think--
DERRICK BASKIN: To be able to
do that with people you like.
SPEAKER 1: Oh, yeah.
That's the other thing.
DERRICK BASKIN:
That's the thing.
Because you don't necessarily
have to like the people
you work with.
You just have to work
with them, right?
And you just have
to get the job done.
But to do it with--
I cut up with these guys
on the stage all the time.
I'm the jokester of the--
JAMES HARKNESS: Constantly.
DERRICK BASKIN: --group.
And I try to break--
I try to break their character
every once in a while
and make them laugh.
And it never really
works, but I try.
SPEAKER 1: You try.
OK.
DERRICK BASKIN: I do that
because I love them and--
not just I love them,
but I really like them.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
DERRICK BASKIN: And not just
these guys, the entire cast.
The women in our
cast are so major.
JAMES HARKNESS: Our women are--
DERRICK BASKIN: They
hold down the cast.
They hold us down.
SPEAKER 1: The band.
DERRICK BASKIN: Yeah,
the band is ridiculous.
They're the top of the top.
We recruited the top of the
top because this music is just
so iconic that you can't
have just a regular--
someone who just
learned to play violin.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
[LAUGHTER]
DERRICK BASKIN: I want
to play Temps music.
[LAUGHTER]
We got the best of the
best supporting us.
But we just genuinely
like each other,
and that just makes it easy.
JAMES HARKNESS: This isn't this
for now, for this interview.
DERRICK BASKIN: Yeah.
JAMES HARKNESS: This
is what it's like.
Before we go on stage
for our first number,
after we circle
up, the stupidity--
I often wonder how much
the audience can hear.
Because right before we go out,
sometimes we are the laughing--
JEREMY POPE: We're still laugh--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JAMES HARKNESS: Until the
second of walking out,
we are laughing because of
something that has happened.
JEREMY POPE: Yeah.
JAMES HARKNESS: And
it's an incredible thing
to get to do that in a show.
'Cause we spend--
I don't know how it
is for you guys here,
but we spend almost half
of our lives, if not more,
at the theater and
with these people.
So to be able to
come into a place
where you look forward to seeing
the people that you work with,
and you look forward
to them every day
because you know,
if nothing else,
you're just going to get this.
SPEAKER 1: Right.
JAMES HARKNESS: And then
to the other perspective,
you're going to get the--
I have-- my stomach has
hurt from laughing so much.
SPEAKER 1: I know the feeling.
JAMES HARKNESS: You
know what I mean?
Or you get-- and you also
get these conversations
where we sit and we talk.
DERRICK BASKIN: Yeah.
JAMES HARKNESS:
We have real talk.
And there's no-- it's
no uncomfortableness.
We're able to actually talk
to each other about life.
SPEAKER 1: I love that.
I love that.
Let's jump into some questions.
But before we do, I
just wanted to make sure
that everyone had an
opportunity to throw
their name into the ticket
draw, as we're giving
away three tickets to the show.
JAMES HARKNESS: And then you can
give me one of those tickets.
SPEAKER 1: And maybe
I can go again, yeah?
[LAUGHTER]
If you have a question, there's
mics set up on both sides.
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So obviously, I think
The Temptations have appealed
to generation after generation.
Who do you feel like is the
craziest type of audience?
Is it the older folks, who
like, this was their music
of their youth?
Or is it people
our age, younger?
JAWAN M. JACKSON: Older folks.
JAMES HARKNESS: The older folks.
We've had--
JEREMY POPE: You have.
JAWAN M. JACKSON: I've had--
[LAUGHTER]
I come out the stage door
and they're screaming.
And then one lady grabbed me
by-- she was an older lady.
She grabbed me by my hoodie and
pulled me and was like, Melvin,
come here.
[LAUGHTER]
And then she pulled
me and she was like,
say something in my
ear in your deep voice.
Say it, say it, say it.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm like, OK.
I'm like, you know I play
the character, right?
I'm not really Melvin.
[LAUGHTER]
It's a testament to the people
that we're playing on stage.
Anytime Eddie goes to
sing, women are screaming.
When David comes around,
his entrance, the audience
goes wild.
And you can just hear they were
just living their teenage years
all over again
because of the bass
line and just the excitement
of David Ruffin coming back.
And everything that's happened--
I think we had underwear thrown
on stage to us, you know?
The experience, it's crazy.
It's crazy.
JAMES HARKNESS: And
it is the older crowd
because like-- was
it a couple of nights
ago, where we had this lady who
sounded like someone's auntie.
And she was like, well?
DERRICK BASKIN: Hello.
JAMES HARKNESS: Hello.
[LAUGHTER]
All right.
DERRICK BASKIN: It's crazy.
JAMES HARKNESS:
We were like, OK.
[LAUGHTER]
There you go.
SPEAKER 1: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
so much for coming.
This was a really
great interview.
My question is-- wait,
I forgot my question.
Oh, I got it.
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
So this came up a bunch of
times in various answers
that the experience of doing
this show, the cast and crew
has been very supportive, and
a lot of warmth and stuff.
What do you all think--
even going back to auditions,
what do y'all think accounts
for that?
Why is that?
Why is it like that?
JAMES HARKNESS: I think
it starts from the top,
and that is with our producers.
They have so much
love for this project.
Tom Hulce and Ira Pittelman.
DERRICK BASKIN: They're here.
JAWAN M. JACKSON: They're here.
JAMES HARKNESS: They are here.
[APPLAUSE]
They have so much
love for this project.
They have been wanting
to put this together
for the longest time.
When that love starts at
the top, it trickles down.
All the people that have
been brought on board,
they all have this love.
What I have said about-- when
people have asked me about what
the rehearsal process has been
like, I was like, we all have--
we've all done enough
stuff as performers,
as producers, as directors,
as choreographers, et cetera,
to have some sort of ego.
And you need an ego to
survive in the world.
You need an ego to
survive in this business.
But what I have loved
about this process
is that ego is put to the side.
Everyone's focus is on this show
and where it needs to get to.
So that's why the experience
has been so supportive.
Everyone's heart is
in the same place.
JAWAN M. JACKSON: We're
here to serve the piece.
I think that's the common goal,
to tell this story truthfully.
And that's with all
19 of us collectively
just coming and making sure
that we tell a story that's
authentic, that's
heartwarming, that gives
back as much as is given to us.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
SPEAKER 1: I think that is it.
JAMES HARKNESS: Two questions?
We got two questions.
SPEAKER 1: Maybe one more.
JAMES HARKNESS: Come on now.
SPEAKER 1: You want to go again?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, is that OK?
SPEAKER 1: Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So this show obviously
is using pre-existing music.
Is it hard to make
these songs that
already exist tell
the story that you're
trying to tell with the show?
JAMES HARKNESS: Absolutely not.
JEREMY POPE: No,
I think what I did
is when I first got the
script, when I was auditioning,
I sat down and I
just read the script
and played the songs
as it went along.
I think we're fortunate that
we know some of these songs
and it's not music that we
have to introduce to you.
So a lot of the times--
and I think Dominique did just
such a brilliant job of using
it to storytell the piece and
to push the piece forward,
and what she's trying to
get across to the audience.
So I think it hasn't been hard.
And I also think there
was never pressure.
People have asked me,
do you have pressure
to imitate the sound or these
icons that you're playing?
And I don't think any of us had
that pressure because we knew
that there was a piece of
Eddie, there was a piece of Paul
within us.
And it was just us being
open to the process
to allow that to come out.
And I don't think you,
at the time, knew.
I didn't know how
similar my voice was
or my essence was to Eddie.
I never was thinking that
is a person I want to play.
But I'm so grateful that I'm
able to portray him and bring
him back for a night--
for the audiences.
So I think just we were--
in the rehearsal process,
it was kind of like bring
yourself to the piece.
Be used in that way.
And then somehow,
the audience response
is you were just like Eddie
and you were just like Otis.
And Derrick doesn't
necessarily look
like a carbon copy of
Otis, but his heart,
his intentions, they're so
grounded that they remind you,
they bring you back
to being in the room
or in the presence
of Otis Williams.
So that's just been really fun.
JAMES HARKNESS: And the lyrical
components of their music--
again, their music is timeless.
You know what I mean?
So a song, "segregation,
determination, demonstration,
integration,
aggravation, humiliation,
obligation to our nation."
Someone could have written
those words today for a song,
but that's "Ball of Confusion,"
which was written in the '70s.
It's not that difficult
with music, with a catalog
like they have.
DERRICK BASKIN: I think they--
first, I'm putting words
into our playwright's mouth,
but you have to first figure
out what story you want to tell.
So I think her and Dez,
and also Tom and Ira,
probably sat around a table
and said, OK, now, there's
a lot of stories you can
tell about The Temptations.
How do we want to
tell it and what is it
that we actually want to tell?
And so once they
figured that out, OK,
now what songs are relevant
to those stories, and how can
we put them--
how can we sequence
them so that we
keep the story moving forward?
And there was a time where
we had one song in the show.
Right before the title song,
which is "Ain't Too Proud,"
we had another song and we
sang those songs back to back.
And then we were like,
well, we don't necessarily
need that song because
it's not necessarily
forwarding the story.
So let's get rid of this song.
And that was my favorite song.
[LAUGHTER]
But I think they figured out
the story they wanted to tell,
and then they picked the
songs based on the story.
We talk about "Papa
Was a Rolling Stone,"
and we use that phrase in
a couple of different ways.
I have a son in the show.
And so we use that to
reference, actually, my son,
you know what I mean?
And so they did a
really, really good job
of making the lyrics
literal to our story.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
First of all, thank you.
In this show, you
portray real people.
For some of you, people
who you met in real life.
How is the process of
working on that role
different than
made-up characters?
Is there a difference?
DERRICK BASKIN: Well, my person
is the only one that's still
living, and we all met him.
We call him Uncle
O. He's our uncle.
Very affectionately,
we call him Uncle O.
And I think he was the window,
or the doorway, for all of us
to get to know all of
our particular characters
because he knows
them intimately.
I got to know him specifically,
but there's no better person
to hear from than someone's best
friend or someone's brother.
He can tell you stories
about Eddie, about Paul,
about Melvin, about
David that you
won't hear in an autobiography.
And so I can't really
speak for them.
Y'all can do that,
but talking with him,
there's just no greater source--
there's no greater
wealth of information
than to actually speak to
the guy you're portraying.
I can read a million
books and it still
won't be enough to having
one sit-down with him
for five to 10 minutes.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you so
much for your question.
Thank you guys again for coming.
Let's give another
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]